sure
and now for uh the last but very much
not the least i'm very much looking
forward to our conversation with that
amalah the ceo of ford ford is just an
an amazing story not just as a symbol of
american
amer america's uh you know at its best
but as a turnaround as well um uh just
uh alan took over uh in uh 2006 um but
uh it was only 2008 2009 when the car
industry was in disarray ford's price i
think dipped intraday below a dollar yes
exactly
at one point and he has just finished um
one of the best quarters in ford's 107
year history and is now worth uh uh 42
billion dollars address we say 42
instagrams or half a faith or half of
facebook
uh but this is a reflection of the sort
of this sort of you know the engine of
american economy
which was creating not you know
extraordinary number of jobs and the
kind of valuations that we've been
talking about in the technology industry
all day um and the sort of disconnect
between the two but uh but tell me a
little bit about what the last six what
you know this extraordinary roller
coaster you've been on for the last few
years well i had this wonderful life of
boeing
and
i was there for 37 years and i had a
chance to serve on the design for all
the boeing commercial airplanes
and i had one more airplane that i
wanted to participate and that was the
replacement of 737
and then i got a call from bill ford of
the ford motor company the great
grandson of henry ford
and he told me about the situation and
as you pointed out
it was pretty tough
and the industry was slowing down
of course the economies were slowing
down fuel prices were moving up
and
it was it was pretty tough and and in
the end i think what really
meant so much to me was i felt like i
was being asked to serve a second
american and global icon and i care
deeply about manufacturing uh
the you know contributing economy energy
independence and security and of course
environmental sustainability and
here i had a chance to you know maybe
help uh you know a second american and
global icon the situation was pretty
tough as you pointed out the first
forecast i
that i was presented uh on the
profitability
for a 2006 and this was september 2006
was a 17 billion dollar loss and we were
able to achieve that
i might point out that you can run out
of money really fast at that rate
and of course you know the situation
where ford was in is that we had become
a house of brands
we had aston martin and jaguar and land
rover and volvo and mazda and of course
ford and lincoln and mercury
and
we were very regionalized and henry ford
set up ford to participate in all the
countries in which he sold vehicle
because he wanted to be part of the the
economy and provide not only great
vehicles but great
great careers and jobs but we were
operating very regionally so we had no
scale to operate with the best global
companies in the world and even though
ford made good vehicles they never made
a commitment to be investing class and
so
against that situation we were losing
money on most of the brands and on most
of the models so clearly we had to move
decisively to a different uh a different
model for ford
so the big decisions that we made uh one
was to focus on the ford brand and we
invested all the others and that was
about 80 of the business worldwide and
the next commitment we made is to
was a brand promise to the consumers
that we would when you walked into a
ford store you you could choose between
a full family of vehicles small medium
large cars utilities and trucks whatever
worked for you
and the next one was that no more just
competitive but we were going to be best
in class and we defined it as history
and chris because it was very universal
around the world
quality fuel efficiency low co2
smart design like sync and my ford and
also safety and the consumers around the
world want those same four
characteristics no matter whether it's a
fiesta or whether it's an f-150 so that
was a wonderfully enabling thing for the
team
and then of course uh the one ford part
of the plan was to use all of our
resources worldwide and bring the
technology and innovation that we had
to deliver on that brand promise and
it's just uh i'm just so
pleased for all the stakeholders
associated with ford that we now have
created and exciting viably properly
going forward and you can remember that
we took it that small home improvement
loan at twenty three and a half billion
dollars
and we actually leveraged the blue oval
the beautiful blue oval that brand
promise and i'm so pleased that now we
have repaid the entire uh alone
and we've moved back to investment grade
with one of the rating agencies and when
we when the second rating agency uh
moves us to investment grade then we get
we get the blue oval back plus all of
our assets and it's so neat now as the
economy is starting to come back that we
have this this great family of vehicles
for the consumers to choose from you
know in uh the other car companies
declared bankruptcy you you did four did
not and now what we've learned from the
airlines is that it is an advantage
first to bankruptcy wins right because
you get to renegotiate labor contracts
etc um how does that play out in the car
in in the car industry um are you at a
disadvantage by not having declared
bankruptcy weirdly enough well that's a
great question chris uh absolutely it's
turned out absolutely not and that was a
big decision that we made and as you all
remember we actually testified on behalf
of our bankrupt competitors
and the reason we did and a lot of
people want to know is because
the u.s at that time and two presidents
and all their economic fighters and we
agreed
if the automobile industry which is
nearly you know 12 to 14 of the us gdp
plus another 10 jobs for everyone in the
in the manufacturing and the enabling
technology sector we could have uh you
know contribute to the united states
going from a recession into a depression
so we actually testified on behalf of
our competitors that they received
temporary money i didn't anticipate that
that we the taxpayer would own them but
um
you know we did believe it was the right
thing to do and i think that we would do
that again now on the other hand um what
was so interesting is that within a week
or so of all the hearings remember the
hearings and there's it's on c-span
that's everywhere
um you know nearly 98 of all the people
the united states knew uh what was
happening they knew
our our competitors were bankrupt they
knew the economy was slowing down
remember the tarp and the financing and
the united states took very aggressive
good action to deal with the situation
but also within a couple of weeks uh
nearly 74 of the people now had checked
in
on the websites checked out all the ford
vehicles and 74 percent were considering
a ford for their next vehicle so the
goodwill of of creating a strong
business that's growing without taking
precious taxpayer money has turned out
to be a just an unbelievably neat thing
for the ford brand so people will fly a
bankrupt airline but they won't buy a
bankrupt car
well i'm really pleased with the ford
plan
all right
on that note we uh we have a uh we
picked the title the notion of the the
cars the ultimate mobile app and and by
that we weren't just talking about the
telematics and the and then the
dashboard etc more the sort of the
notion of a network um you know
increasingly i was uh you know as
visiting the tesla factory and in in
silicon valley which is basically a car
you know electric car and you now make
electric cars they're like laptops on
wheels right lithium-ion batteries um
you know tons of software uh basically
designed around the battery composite
frames you know it's basically you could
apple could be making you know a car
because many of the same manufacturing
techniques um exist and so that
integration between you know the
electric networks the telecommunication
networks and the human networks the sort
of the sort of interactions we expect
with our devices is what we were going
for with that with that uh that metaphor
of a mobile app but when when you think
of the car as an app i mean do you mean
it to mean sort of an extension of your
phone in that way absolutely and this is
such a an exciting development remember
those four pillars of the quality the
fuel efficiency the safety and the smart
design
when we were watching the consumer
electronics industry evolve especially
with the smart phones
then it was really clear to us that
the consumer would not want to have a
disconnected life they want to have one
life they want to have they want to be
connected inside the vehicle as well as
outside the vehicle and then another
thing that was very interesting chris on
the convergence of the technology
roadmap on the vehicle because clearly
we're moving from internal combustion
engines whether the petrol or diesel to
more alternative fuels including you
know biomass and ethanol and especially
natural gas now but also the one that
really looks promising are the
electrifications of the vehicles and
we're still working on uh a tremendous
possibility and that is in hydrogen
where you could and then we could
actually be generating the energy clean
and then using it clean which would be
you know what we all want
and so when we decided that we were all
going to be paying more for the inter
for energy and we adopted this
technology road map and just like your
point about the electric vehicles today
so
from ford you can get a not only a
petrol or diesel that's the most
efficient as class but you can get a
hybrid you get a plug-in hybrid with a
little bit bigger battery like the ones
that you're mentioning the tesla or you
can get an electric vehicle like tesla
has
and uh depending on what your lifestyle
is you have the power of choice from
ford now beginning back to your thought
about the integrated solution
so that the applications that we are
developing now with microsoft and and
the our other technology partners is
that you can manage your life through
your smartphone also because we didn't
want to build the capability into the
vehicle we wanted to move with the
consumer electronic speed and capability
so
our system is all voice activated hands
are on the wheel eyes are on the road
and then use the capability of the
smartphone that you bring in which means
you also can use that capability outside
the vehicle so take the the new focus
electric which you know 100
over 100 miles per hour per gallon
equivalent on the fuel efficiency
you can from anywhere inside the car
outside the car you can check your car
you can check it's charged
you can check
all the stations
where the route that you want to go and
where you can charge which ones are
available you can also use the
applications that the energy companies
and microsoft are working on
that you can also find out where on the
grid is the right time to charge and
when to charge when's the most
economical time to charge and you can
also do set the charging by your phone
also so it's almost like your mobile app
point of view is that that we want to
make it so easy for you to adopt have
the vehicle that works for you as far as
the energy source but for you to be able
to manage that in your life
i was recently shopping for a car and it
is there's never been harder to buy a
car today because of the the all these
technology directions these energy
directions you know should i should i go
for you know for hybrid should i go for
plug hybrid should i go for pure
electric should i go for diesel should i
go for high efficiency gas should i go
for you know lng or for you know and and
and you know clearly you know one of
these or several of these are going to
win and some will not um but it's you
feel like you're at one of these kind of
transition phases between the industry
as it was for 100 years in the industry
as it will be for the next hundred years
and it's very difficult to know as a
regular consumer which will win is it
difficult as a ceo before have a car
company to to to make the same bets well
on one hand
it certainly is on the other hand
because we really don't know which one
is going to be the preferred longer term
solution
then we need to invest in all of them
and that's why we chose that that road
map because with our scale
whatever improvement we make with this
internal combustion engine with direct
fuel injection or turbo charging
and whatever we do with our
electrification or our hydrogen
because of our scale we make a
tremendous contribution to fuel
efficiency of co2 reduction so our plan
is to keep investing in each of the
technologies and then migrate it up
through that clean road map i think
another thing that's going to is
happening around the world and also in
the united states is where do we where
do we as citizens of the world really
want to go with energy and what's our
energy policy to get us there because
you know clearly the use of the energy
in a clean way is is important but also
the generation of the energy is going to
be very important and we're very
gratified that we're seeing more
conversation public-private partnership
government leadership about where do we
really want to go
the neat thing about a company like ford
is that we're right in the intersection
of those big things that we all care
about
it's so important that we grow the
economy for the good of all of us
it's also important that we're making
progress on energy independence but also
energy security
uh and also that we're contributing to
their long-term term goals of
environmental sustainability and so it's
a neat thing about ford to deal with
those but also to pull everybody in to
deal with them together because we've
got some big decisions to make as a
citizens of the world
building on this sort of you know how do
you make decisions in the last three
years we've gone from a world where we
were running out of gas you know prices
were going up you know
gas was associated with the middle east
and
and and global conflict um and that
there was a you know a strong push
towards renewables and solar and et
cetera
tune one now where we've got shale oil
we've got you know we're we've got
natural gas burbling out you know that
the you know the the fracking spouts um
that we're you know close to you know
energy independence and and the
cleantech world is in decline because
there's you know because um uh the
economics um don't compare to this newly
efficient fossil fuel world so you know
dramatic change in the place of you know
fossil fuels in our energy spectrum how
does that change your thinking well the
point of view that we have taken uh and
the reason that is behind all of our
investments is we really have taken a
point of view
that we all are going to pay more for
energy going forward worldwide and it's
all going to be driven by economic
development worldwide and especially
you know the mature markets are big
but the developing markets are are going
to grow even faster and especially when
you look at india and china where we
have
very significant operations so the
reason that we are focusing so much on
fuel efficiency and co2 reduction is
that it is a reason to buy because the
economics are going to
people are going to be looking for
economical
solutions both for the quality the fuel
efficiency and the
and the safety the thing that we are
going to continue to do is to work with
all the governments around around the
world to help just keep help
facilitating this dialogue about where
do we really want to go with energy and
which kinds of energy but in the
meantime we need to invest in in each of
those because we it's clear not clear
now which one is going to be the one
that comes on the fastest so you don't
feel that the
advances in oil exploration and
extraction over the past couple years
have changed in any way
the long-term view of what we're going
to need we absolutely because we uh
clearly you know fossil fuels are going
to be with us for a while and to your
point when it comes to energy density
they are they lend themselves so much
better to you know transportation but
the new ones are like like natural gas
on the bigger vehicles we don't have the
constraints of the packaging with the
big tanks they're fantastic but also we
need the infrastructure to be put in
place so that we can use it same thing
on the electric grid as you pointed out
a really exciting possibility to us
is the fact that as we bring on more
efficient batteries and the grids are
generally sized for the peak hours and
they're not used on the off peak but you
can imagine
to a world that's not very far away that
with very efficient batteries we'll be
able to store the electricity be able to
move the electricity between our house
between our vehicles between the
utilities and then if we then also focus
on how to generate that energy clean i
think we're going to make a lot of
progress to where we all want to get
tell me a little bit more about the the
economics of the batteries um so you
were recently speaking you were
describing what it costs what the
battery pack for like the the new ford
focus electric
is um can you tell a little bit about
how you think about the cost of a
battery pack as a as a ceo and as a kind
of a product planner oh you bet um
what chris is talking about is that we
revealed a little bit about the size and
the packaging and the cost of these
batteries
and uh it's very interesting if you just
take a
say a hybrid and a plug-in hybrid and an
all-electric
and a
hybrid
the battery could be maybe a 1.5 1.7
kilowatt hour battery it can weigh
around 100 pounds and costs around 2
000.
and what's neat about that is you
operate on electricity for a portion so
if like for if you're not running very
many miles that's great but if also you
need the flexibility of a longer range
you also have an internal combustion
engine that can provide that if you go
to a plug-in then you have the ability
to charge it you also have the ability
to operate on all electricity even in a
bigger way because the battery's bigger
but also you have an internal combustion
engine also to support you for longer
ranges
and that battery
could be
you know say like a 7.5 kilowatt
hour battery it could weigh 200 to 300
pounds
and cost maybe six to eight thousand
dollars
now if you move to the all-electric
battery and just using the lithium-ion
chemistry for the battery today
moving off the nickel metal hydride that
you can get a battery that weighs about
600 to 800 pounds it's a 23 kilowatt
kilowatt hour battery and it costs
between 13 and fifteen thousand dollars
now you can imagine to the point because
you mentioned the focus and you look at
our
lineup uh the focus and the fiesta the
focus the fusion the tourists the
mustang the escape
all those small and medium-sized
vehicles that you can imagine that on
vehicles that cost you know 22 to 25 000
you're adding you know 15 000 battery
which is why you see the ranges for the
all-electric vehicles being in the 35 to
40 000 now as energy goes up
you can make an economic case that
you're going to it's a benefit because
of the
fuel that you save but that's why the
most important thing that we do that the
industry is doing all of us are doing is
how do we make more efficient lighter
weight
uh more affordable batteries which is
not which is going to not a benefit just
to us but it's going to benefit
everybody in the industry well tell me
more about that fifteen thousand dollars
for a battery pack and what is the range
and that you get from that and all
electric he could be over a hundred
miles okay so
15 thousand dollars for a hundred mile
range which is pretty much what people
need except
um now we don't have a moore's law of
lithium
battery chemistry it declines but not at
the rates we're used to in the
semiconductor industry um
what
when you look at the future do you see
breakthroughs on on the horizon or
what's going to change with that i think
so and i you know we we're very pleased
with the progress we made with lithium
ion batteries especially off the nickel
metal hydride but i think that some of
the exciting things that we're seeing
for the enabling technology is they're
going to be new chemistries that are
going to allow us to not only
make the batteries smaller but also
lighter weight and another key thing
about batteries is their ability to
charge both in hot and cold temperatures
and and hold their charge
uh and i think another thing that's
going to happen is we that with the
charging technology we can be able to
get the charging times down and you've
seen some of ours that are down in the
three to four hours now which again goes
back to the whole lifestyle how do you
live with this with this basic
technology but i think with the effort
that we're putting uh into the
neighboring technology we're gonna see
some great breakthroughs in the not too
distant feature
china has made battery technology a you
know core national priority uh they want
this to be the sort of the oil fields um
that they that they can dominate uh can
america compete in battery production oh
absolutely and i i think it goes at the
at the heart of american technology and
innovation it's been it's been what has
powered manufacturing you know 70
percent i think because of all the
research and development in the united
states the united states is still
associated with manufacturing
manufacturing with a big m
and our ability to design and create and
innovate with these kind of solutions
especially with something that's so
important to not only the automobile
industry but all of industry as
batteries there's no reason that we
can't continue to compete with the best
in the world are we going to
we don't have labor efficiencies and the
lithium is in bolivia or something
what's our strength here well the in the
lithium chemistry itself there are a
number of sources as as you're alluding
to so uh it's more of like a commodity
that that is available on i find it
interesting the conversation about
competitiveness and wages and benefits
because it's not that you have to have
the lowest but you have to have the most
innovative and the and the most uh
creative right because that's what's
made us strong
is
our effect of pursuing enabling
technology and then innovating with that
to provide solutions that the customers
really do want
and
i'm just one of the things that we did
that we didn't talk about is
our our cost structure member in the
united states was such that we couldn't
make smaller vehicles in the united
states and make them profitable
so we pulled all the stakeholders
together and especially
our unions and our that transformation
agreement that we made going from
defined benefits to defined contribution
the entry-level wages were competitive
that made sense the retiree healthcare
we dealt with that with a separate via
that we financed and also simplifying
all the work rules we now are competing
with the best companies in the world
right here in the united states and
what's so neat
is that um we're also with the
flexibility that we have in our plants
that that petrol version of the focus
the hybrid the plug-in hybrid and
all-electric are all off the same
production line and we can match now
what you want we can match that
production to the real demand and we're
doing it right here in the united states
and we're bringing work back to the
united states because we're competing so
that's very exciting so you're moving
car production back to the united states
absolutely from
from right now to mexico really
interesting from mexico to the united
states because you've got the economics
of manufacturing in america absolutely
better terrific um so we have um we're
going to be moving to q a um and uh
there's been a couple of questions over
twitter and then i'm going to take
questions let me start with one question
from
from uh from the twitter uh
audience and then we'll move to the
audience here um the question was did
you ever think was ever every sort of
moment of doubt where you thought that
ford might in fact go bankrupt that you
wouldn't be able to turn it around and
and what if anything much would you have
done differently in hindsight
wow
well
i think my
my thought about that question that
really is associated with
what was happening in the united states
because uh clearly when we uh when we
borrowed our small home improvement loan
and we restructured the business and
then we
actually accelerated the investment of
all these new uh vehicles
no one could have anticipated where the
economy was going in the banking crisis
and
the sovereign debt crisis
and we we borrowed more money than we
actually needed for the transformation
but uh because we knew that and you know
things were slowing down but uh it was
pretty you know united states was in a
very very precarious position as you
know um and so i think it was more
against that backdrop of the of the
entire economy in the united states
i never had doubt
that we could transform forward because
in the automobile business the
investment you make to compete on the
world stage if you have a point of view
about where you're going with the
product line and what the customers
really value and what they want the
amount of money that you invest every
year you can transform a company in
three or four years i think i know this
might not sound like a um
might sound interesting to everybody but
one of the things i was most concerned
about was the culture of ford and bill
ford had shared with me that the kremlin
came to mind a couple of times when he
was telling me about it and the
infighting and and the businesses didn't
operate as one company and i can
remember i was how was i going to break
through that to create a safe
environment where everybody knew what
the plan is what the status was we were
working together so i started our
business plan review every thursday
morning seven o'clock all the business
unit leaders from around the world all
the skill teams like product development
which has been well documented so we got
the data flowing we color coded the
charts you know red yellow and green how
it's going remember we saw it i just had
seen a um i have been shared a
our profit forecast a 17 billion dollar
loss and all 300 charts were green
and i finally stopped the meeting at one
time and i said you know
we're gonna lose 17 billion dollars is
there anything that's not going well
throughout the ford empire and of course
eye contact to the floor
and because they didn't know me and you
know i'm saying that we wanted a safe
environment so
a couple weeks later everything's green
and then
mark fields who runs the americas had a
launch of a new escape in oakville
canada
and they had an issue with the actuator
on the on the rear door and we had made
a commitment absolutely the finest
quality where we were going to deliver
the vehicle so we stopped the production
line had about three thousand uh um
edges out there
and
and so the business plan review starts
we get the mark section up comes this
chart for the launches and here is
bright red bright on the technology
right on the schedule and bright on the
cost and i mean it got really quiet now
we're gonna find out what this guy's
really like mark's out of here gone
toast
and
so mark explained it and i started to
clap and then they thought that really
is a sign the door's gonna open
mark's out of here because that's what
happened before
and that's that's great visibility and
uh is there anything we can do team to
help
and i remember joe
or
derek cusack was head of product
development time said you know i think
i've seen an issue like that on such and
such i'll get you that technical data um
benny fowler who ran quality so i saw
that on the launch blah blah blah i
guess the data joe henricks who was
leading manufacturers said well you're
gonna we're gonna find the issue we're
gonna get we're gonna get a solution and
we're going to need to turn these
vehicles around that are already made so
i'm going to get you some manufacturing
engineers and get them up to canada
right away that interchange took maybe
10 seconds and went to the next chart
green green green green
maybe next week or two weeks later
mark's chart turned to yellow they found
the problem had a design solution the
next week
i think it maybe turned to green
and all the vehicles started flowing
around the world and then to your point
the most
place where i practiced emotional
resilience the most was the next week
when the entire rainbow
the entire set of charts looked like a
rainbow
because
everybody decided it was safe we'd broke
it through that part and now not only do
we know why we're losing 17 billion
dollars but now we could all pull
together on this plan to make this full
family of best-in-class vehicles and
help each other get it done
i love the expression you practiced
emotional resilience yes
let me take some questions here from uh
from the audience so starting over here
please
hi uh rich greenfield over at btig
question about you know is the car gets
ip enabled
do you envision
actual wireless technology being built
right into the car do you think it'll
end up really being driven off of the
mobile device whether it's a tablet or a
smartphone and then just related to that
you know in the the current radio world
satellite radio has been a huge boon for
the car industry with kind of a
one-click button for satellite as you
move to the ip world with the pandoras
the spotifys and the ihearts will it be
a free-for-all do you expect certain
winners or do you think the consumer
will have just lots of choices in the
car with no one clear winner like
happened in satellite absolutely and on
the first question at the latter and on
the second question the latter
and and i know you know what you asked
but that is exactly the way we're
thinking about it the reason that we
took out all of the embedded part was
that we wanted to operate at the speed
of the consumer electronics so
everything about our system and sync and
myford is the use of smart devices
and then we also made the decision that
the best thing for the use inside an
automobile was voice activation so you
could keep your hands on the wheel and
your eyes on the road and on all of the
other application programs like pandora
or whatever the ones that you described
the consumer will decide which of those
uh are the are the will be the the
applications of choice and we'll make
those uh available in the vehicle but
what we want to do is remember the old
days where everything was embedded in
the car
well it's moving so fast that we want to
actually keep that interface uh clean
and then we have the operating system
and then we manage the driving
experience while the consumer
electronics brings the apps to the car
that's a really another really good
point is that we made this a reason to
buy for not to make money off of it
ourselves so that's why when we say
quality and fuel efficiency saving smart
design we want this to be a reason to
buy not to have to pay for it
because that it's almost like chris said
earlier he said that he heard somebody
talking about ford and they were
one of the comments we made was ford the
mobile app of choice i mean that
you know what i mean
we'll meet you right outside and take
care of your
needs uh we have a question over here
over here on the side of the audience um
bringing one over there thank you um
richard titus uh uh i'm the producer of
a movie called who killed the electric
car
um first i want to say well done in uh
embracing the new technologies that you
guys have done i mean ford's made a real
turnaround um however my question is as
the owner proud owner and investor in
tesla which my car goes 200 miles on any
charge
why are we still building crippled
vehicles that only go 100 miles per
charge
well i think in in our case uh it's it's
fundamentally the economics and the
customers that we're serving because as
you well know um
let's come back to henry ford's original
vision of opening the highways to all
mankind
is that where we the customer set that
we have is to get it to everybody the
democratization of technology and so
just like those sequences of the
different options for electric vehicles
uh we clearly see that the majority of
the electrification will be the hybrids
first then the plug-in hybrids and then
all the electric from a volume point of
view so it's all based on economics and
getting as much of that technology to as
many people as we possibly can
well i i know we have more questions but
unfortunately i think you have a plane
to catch um and we have to race you uh i
do out to the airport so uh please join
me in thanking alan thank you
you